I believe that producing content on an
everyday basis at scale is the answer to
98 of the questions in this room about
their businesses the nonprofit you want
to get somebody elected all of the above
it is the answer the ability to post
produce for Facebook Twitter Instagram
Snapchat your podcast your Vlog your
text messaging platform that you're
going to have Tick Tock the ability to
understand how a picture or a video or
written sentence Works different on
every one of those nine platforms is the
unlock that is my deep religion I do not
use a platform to post a photo to all
the platforms because I understand that
they have to be unique within the
environment they're delivered you the
same person LinkedIn is different than
that person an hour later on Instagram
because your mindset's different context
matters and so many people just want to
check the box of putting out content
they don't understand that the reason
I'm winning across every platform is
because of the context not the content